c'est une soirée du 31 qui aura fait
grand bruit en cette fin d'année 2020
cette soirée du réveillon qui joue les
prolongations la rave party géante se
poursuit à lieuron jusqu'à 2500
personnes se sont réunies l'organisation
d'une rave party dans des hangars
désaffectés avec plus de 2500
participants dans l'ouest de la france à
lieuron soirées clandestines qui a duré
près de 72 heures avec des forces de
l'ordre dans l'incapacité d'intervenir
via les voies de victimes de jets projet
qu'ils peuvent être arrêtés a fait
violent nous dit-on ce soir en
exclusivité dans tpm paix nous recevons
une participante à cet événement que
tout le monde pointe du doigt elle va
s'exprimer pour la première fois et le
docteur martin de lâcher nous donnera
son point de vue merci martin blachier
d'être avec nous et je sais que vous
êtes colère après cette rave party cette
rave party c'est incroyable 1 2500
personnes trois jours et ça a duré trois
jours nous on se fait chier à huy est à
6 à la maison dès cet été comme ça et
oui je peux tenir
tu te dis je je vais prendre perpète
je tenais la gamme de là je suis au
placard comme ça quoi tu es là pourquoi
on était sept à la maison j'ai pris deux
ans aux frères à sébazac actionner je
veux dire entre deux minutes et 6 sont
arrivés et là c'est le gobie du
cauchemar complet
c'est ça le et c'était 2500 ouais j'ai
vraiment des infos sur cette histoire
sachez déjà que quand ils étaient 4 par
voiture par exemple
alors la rave party en fait et dit viser
la menthe par 4 1 by paris vrai
ah ouais donc bon après ça tu ça coûtait
35 euros en fait à peu près on n'a qu'à
me qui a participé à ses traits à partie
un mur on salue caméra
voilà et voilà la mascc salut camille
bon c'était bien la fête quand même bah
ouais ouais
alors il est alors est pas totalement
remis
vous appelle les teufeurs de cette rave
party mac amis et vous dit vous avez
moins peur d'aller en teuf qu'au
supermarché
ah ouais parce que je pense que au
supermarché fin il ya trois ou quatre
mille personnes qui passent par jour bah
touche tous les produits les remettre en
rayon
c'est fermé c'est pas enfin alors que là
on était en teuf on était dans un hangar
les deux portes étaient ouvertes
il y avait assez distante al ain de
distance abbas a pas d'accord et pour
bouger vous attrape des combattants à
cette fête camille pourquoi je suis
arrivé le vendredi à midi et je suis
reparti de ce tome 10 à 5 heures c'est
une belle à une bonne fête alors est
comment vous avez eu l'info de cette
trêve parce que nous on n'était pas au
con par exemple 1 je sais qu isabelle
voulait venir verront en fait le
problème c'est qu'il faut se faire des
potes dans le bas dans le dans le milieu
quoi dans le milieu des teufeurs ouais
mais c'est très fermé ouais c'est pas
mal on sera sur les roseaux c'est c'est
fermé pour les flics ont fait parce que
ma mère est d'accord est-ce que c'était
dur d'y accéder à cette fête
non du tout mais il y avait les flics
qui était de ventre en bronze et je suis
passé devant à pied c'est gronderait
quoi ils étaient les politiques et non
mais vous il paraît que c'est votre mère
qui vous a mené away
ah ouais d'accord et votre mère vous a
pas dit c'est pas bien tout ça se
comprend il m'a elle m'a dit que c'était
juste de faire attention en fait c'est
tout alors il y en a même qui veut
qu'ils vont jusqu'à vous qualifiez de
punks à chiens drogués qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez alors je les emmerde
oui surtout en fait le problème c'est
que punk à chien en fait tu peut pas
traiter tes semblables de punks à chien
c'est pas possible en fait c'est de
l'irrespect sais c'est pas respectueux
de traiter des semblables à la caisse a
peut être ton fils ton cousin ton 9h
n'importe qui c'est c'est des semblables
alors on a reçu de nombreux témoignages
de fêtards le coiffeur voilà on faisait
ces pagnes ensuite moi aussi j'étais un
peu gâchée à l'époque j'avais un chef
les il y en a plein qui faisait part de
la passivité de certains membres des
forces de l'ordre des contrôles beaucoup
ont reçu une seule amende pour tous les
occupants d'une voiture ce qu'ils
faisaient 135 euros à partager à
plusieurs soit d amende de 33 euros par
personne 6 et t4 selon plusieurs proches
des organisateurs de la rave party se
sont pas eux qui ont été interpellés ce
week end à l'issue de la fête les
véritables organisateurs ne serait pour
l'instant pas inquiété si si si ça y est
un réalisateur qui a été mis en examen
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
donc c'est un an d'emprisonnement et de
15000 euros damende alors martin de la
chine quand vous entendez cette jeune
fille qui est très sympa d'ailleurs de
deux témoigné un mine de rien voilà le
fai y en a plein qui ont pas vous razr
donc merci déjà et le pauvre son courage
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec ses
parents qu est ce que vous vous avez ce
que vous lui dites je dis non non c'est
très grave de faire une fête comme ça
parce qu'ils sont 2500 donc la
probabilité qu'ils en aient un
quelconque vide elle est quand même
assez élevée mais elle peut contaminer
des centaines de personnes donc pour ces
personnes là c'est pas grave ils sont
jeunes ils sont dans la force de l'âge
ils vont faire une forme à symptômes
atik après vont contaminer un copain qui
va en bout de chaîne contaminé une
personne âgée est ingénieur celui qui
organise une fête comme ça il est
peut-être potentiellement responsable de
la mort d'une dizaine de personnages et
potentiellement donc oui c'est très
grave tués de janvier
l'avis des téléspectateurs là dessus un
aussi donc pour vous c'est inadmissible
ah oui c'est gravissime et en tout cas
la peine n'a que j'entends pour moi
c'est tout à fait proportionnée par
rapport à la gravité d'organiser ce type
d'événement du radi est ce qu'on peut
savoir ce que vous avez fait depuis vous
avez terminé c'est très vives que vous
être isolé vous vous êtes fait tester
c'est quoi votre votre règle de conduite
pendant ce temps non je me fais pas
testé je préviens c'est un boulot demain
et s'ils veulent un jour je me serais
tester et par rapport à votre famille
vous avez des gens autour de vous plus
âgés ou à risque ou je ne sais pas non
j'habite tout seul chiffre
on veut défendre
il faut savoir que quand vous avez 18
ans aujourd'hui en france à faire un an
que vous ne pouvez pas faire la fête
avec vos amis donc socialement c'est
très compliqué concrètement quand vous
êtes dans un studio vous ne pouvez rien
faire pour moi je me suis demandé si
dans le reste du monde c'était le cas et
s'il y avait des boîtes de nuit ou non
et j'ai recherché sur les réseaux
sociaux
regardez les images ouais je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait il ya plein de
pays où les boîtes de nuit sont encore
ouvertes au port
c'est la folie personnes 8000 personnes
là ici en inde
voilà et tout ça c'est son masque
évidemment dubaï évidemment tout le
monde d'aller faire la fête à petit à
goa en inde a way to b tulum au mexique
hier soir cette nuit dans un restaurant
de voilà ce que je veux dire c'est comme
une hypocrisie mais jamais celle de se
dire quand vous êtes un jeune là vous
vous tout le monde déjà on est un âge où
on sort plus forcément en boîte de nuit
aujourd'hui à 18 ans comment pour
rencontrer des gens socialement elle est
tout seul dans un studio comprenez je te
dit guillaume là ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec lui je vais bien sûr que
je comprends l'es20 je comprends surtout
que en fait
balas essaie juste de l'injustice envers
les teufeurs parce que c'est évident c
c'est de la musique qui plaît pas tous
hein c'est si du boum boum c'est du
bruit là c'est non mais c'est pas
vraiment ça le problème
la musique n'est pas le problème nicolas
pernikoff attend j'avais juste une
question vous parliez tout à l'heure de
d'irrespect est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression des gens comme nous par
exemple la majorité des français pour
avoir l'impression que vous êtes un peu
irrespectueux d'aller faire une fête à
2500 alors qu'on est tous on vient de
passer le pire noël et le csii pierre
nouvel an s'il allait nous les
françaises et les français qui sont
restés chez eux
il ya des gens qui souffrent et les gens
qui crèvent et des soignants qui sont là
pour nous il ya des policiers qui sont
débordés par les événements et vous êtes
là en train de nous dire que c'est
irrespectueux de vous traiter de punk
prochain je suis excuses
et vous pensez pas qu'il ya un problème
la caisse conviennent fonda sa cabine ah
ouais parce que nous on n'aide personne
en fait on était en danger les noms je
sais pas on n'a jamais arrêté lecteurs
alors pourquoi le kovy dollar est très
efficace
je comprend effectivement très bien que
je n'ai envie de faire la fête c'est
normal et moi j'ai des enfants qui n'en
peuvent plus sur la maison moi ce que je
comprends pas c'est qu'ils sont resté
trente six heures dans un hangar avec de
la musique et la lumière il y avait des
dons des gendarmes qui étaient dehors
pourquoi il coupa le courant ou le
groupe l'étranger nasria il ya plus de 7
mais il fallait on a laissé faire 36
heures et honnêtement il y a
des deux côtés effectivement ils sont
ensemble c'est très dangereux et on
voudra pas reparlé évidemment qu'il ya
un risque de contaminer des autres mais
la vérité c'est ça 36 ans et cinq ans
les ados 36 heures marc bacci vous vous
vous êtes assez répressif un naturel
d'aller parler à la fois sur la bande à
milito ça ça vous révolte ça vraiment
crise bah ouais on est on sait on a des
études qui montrent que ce genre
d'événements peuvent être responsables
de centaines de milliers de
contamination ça peut relancer une
épidémie au niveau local donc c'est sûr
que tout le monde va avoir énormément de
mal à rattraper si jamais ça lance un
cluster à l'échelle régionale en plus ça
éparpillés dans toute la france parce
que les germains toute la france avec ça
peut essaimer dans tout le reste du pays
ont fait des efforts considérables pour
essayer de contenir cette épidémie on se
vaccine ça coûte des fortunes tout le
monde est à l'arrêt mais en fait ce sont
les autres jeunes qui vont devoir rester
enfermés dans leur appartement plus
longtemps parce que certains se sont
permis d'organiser ce type de fait n'ont
pas laissé une envie de faire la fête
c'est égoïste et vous croyez pas les
locaux
les restaurateurs vous pensez pas qu'ils
ont envie de reprendre le boulot oui les
directeurs de salle et sur mi temps du
spectacle les techniciens les patrons de
boîtes de théâtre de cinéma
tout le monde a envie de se sortir la
tête de l'eau et eux ils viennent
sacrifier leurs efforts tandis que eux
ils ne peuvent plus vivre ils n'ont plus
d'argent et tout ça parce que vous vous
avez envie de faire la teuf les gens
l'ignorent va être vachement bien
sacrifier tous leurs efforts juste parce
qu'urs égoïsme mais la raison non mais
bien sûr que oui isabelle on passe d'une
génération et l'autre ici dans cette
émission il ya quinze génération wii
vous aimez admis neveu et rêveur un
petit lot assez peu après oui tout à
fait s'agace jean patrick et de noms
avec l'anneau dans l'horreur bon remake
un tout la pénombre à son nom mais
d'abord petit as qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire de dire dans les
supermarchés encore plus de risques
parce qu'elle correspond à un objet
comparer l'un et l'autre ou montrer des
fêtes partout dans le monde entier c'est
pas parce qu'ils sont cons ailleurs
qu'on est obligés de l'être que du sida
mort deuxièmement ensuite dire non on
est jeune on veut profiter de notre vie
mais un dans 6 mois ne peuvent leur
reprendre leur vie les personnes qui
sortent pas senti le besoin en eau la
ddt depuis la raison
voilà je connais une personne qui tente
dans sa chambre confiné depuis six mois
dans les flandres et elle voudrait pas
aussi sortir un peu arrêtez arrêtez
d'être des monstres d'égoïsme par
moments quand vous entendez ces exemples
camille ça vous fait réfléchir ou pas du
tout enfin
parce que je trouve que déjà les écoles
le métro le self les élections de miss
france enfin tout ça c'est par respect
qu'elle entendait surtout réveiller data
alors non mais tu fais ne sont pas les
le problème mais c'est quelque chose
dont tout eu ahmed
parce qu'en fait la l'impression que
c'est contre les teufeurs mais ça aurait
été la même chose si ça a été
2500 campagnard qui va à la fête à la
campagne moi j'ai fait la fête on était
diminué
on était tous testés on est revenue je
me suis refait testées pourraient pour
être cool
là c'est juste en fait en groupe comme
la france à elle elle est confinée
depuis huit mois qu'on a tous besoin de
faire la fête moi le premier j'adore ça
et que c'est un mais c'est juste par
rapport aux autres par rapport aux
personnes fragiles et c'est là qu'il
faut faire attention
est-ce que vous l'êtes à retourner en
teuf prochainement camille bien sûr que
vous en fichez totalement de de
contaminer peut-être les gens qui un
jean et des millions de gens et des
milliers de personnes deviendront alors
c'est sûr d'accord le belge en tout cas
camille sée votre avis on n'est pas
d'accord avec vous du tout martin qu'est
ce que vous diriez à cette jeune fille
faisons la foule a sensibilisé jeu
donnera un petit message d'espoir je
dirais dans quatre mois vous allez
pouvoir faire la teuf si jamais cette
campagne de vaccination trouve le bon
chemin donc faut attendre quatre mois et
quatre mois vous êtes jeunes ou encore
plein de choses à faire c'est peut-être
que vous arrêterez à 36 ans les 35 ans
de faire des teufs mois à raison de une
personne vaccinée par jour
tantôt merde pas la socar ni mais
assurent des cadets merci d'avoir été là
qu'à lumière du cas merci
elle a beaucoup d'humour salut qu'à me
[Musique]
kami allait dépenser j'adore